what was the first first big role the
first thing you did
well you know what thinking back talking
about my early childhood as a kid in new
york i auditioned this is how old i am
on golden pond
you auditioned for on golden pond was
this movie like 1980 yeah 80 78 right so
that i was about eight years old i'm in
this game 45 years man
wow yeah and i remember not getting the
part and i had a great exchange with
mark rydell who was so cool even to me
as a little kid
because i remember him breaking the news
to me and basically said it's not gonna
work out and they hired doug mckean who
was the kid in the film so that's how
far i go back you know and then i did
commercials and it was just kind of like
a hobby that spun you know into some
work so the first big one to your
question was like vacation chevy chase
and what was what was that audition like
do you remember auditioning for that i
remember walking in and meeting matty
simmons he was a great guy uh we lost
him a couple years ago he created
lampoon magazine and i remember meeting
harold ramus and maddie on that day you
went in for the first audition for all
the vacations yeah yeah and what was
your audition do you remember what scene
i don't really know i don't remember
what scene but it was something probably
with chevy one of the scenes maybe chevy
was there no no but it was probably the
scene in the desert with chevy you know
it was probably one of those scenes i
don't i don't recall were you drinking
the beer yeah it was probably one but
you didn't have you didn't meet chevy
before you got the part no no just
maddie and harold remus so that was a
big that that was really cool what's
interesting too is john hughes actually
wrote that screenplay i didn't read him
then right so
his trajectory was interesting he
started selling short stories to lampoon
magazine right he had been a copywriter
in chicago he wrote and that's what
she's having a baby is that context so
kevin bacon's playing him
liz mcgovern was playing his wife and uh
so he sold this short story next thing
you know they made it into the film i
did that film didn't know john and then
right after that i did 16 candles in
audition form and then right as a kid
and then did three in a row with him
yeah but vacation man
that that is
i always think of like people when they
work with chevy chase because you always
hear things you hear things i've had uh
joel mchale he was on here and he talked
about it he loves chevy but like you
know there was some problems on set
yeah on the community and things happen
and you know he got fired and all these
all these things do you remember him
being very
giving and and nurturing and kind of
like guiding you because you had to be
nervous as or were you not
oh i was nervous yeah as a kid
absolutely by the time i did community
no i had a different take on it but i
had a great time on that show i mean
there were so many great actors on that
show all the whole cast was cool and um
i you know i worked with him briefly on
that yeah
though i'm talking about on vacation i
mean i was just i was rusty i was 14
years old so i looked up to everybody
man you know john john candy was great
john candy really was
a big personality and a lot of fun what
was it about him well chevy was kind of
like the way he is kind of snarky and
funny you know what i mean but candy was
uncle buck man he was really and the way
it happened was we shot one ending it
didn't work and it was that thing where
the studio tested it they got the cards
back and they realized
from the original ending that they never
made it to wally world so we regrouped
six months later puberty kicked in i'm
like four inches taller i get to the set
at magic mountain i got a huge zit on my
chin cherry's like nice okay you're
jerking off good to see you've grown
uh
it was just probably but that's how
chevy was yeah yeah no he said uh yeah
something like that if you're blind
you're doing it right meaning i was
whacking off i don't know what it tally
was saying um and then they hired john
candy and that's the ending we shot that
they used so the test screening came
back and the audience was like we
want to see them make it to wally world
they never did so that's not what
happened then we re-shot the ending and
we did it did you think the movie was
going to be i mean you hear this all the
time you have no idea you never know i
think anybody who says that they knew
when they were making something i i
think that that's a i think that's bs
you never really know i mean i had a
great time and i was working with all
these legends you know
but as a kid i wasn't processing the
future success